Welcome to the course on jQuery.
I'm excited to be able to take you through a quick tour of the jQuery library.
Over 60% of the top 100,000 most visited websites take advantage of
jQuery's simple syntax and powerful DOM manipulation methods.
In this course, you'll experience firsthand why jQuery's so
popular as you explore the features that it has to offer.
You'll start by breaking down how the jQuery library is built with
JavaScript and what that means for your code.
Then you'll dive into jQuery selectors and DOM navigation methods.
This is probably the trickiest and most important part of learning jQuery.
But once you've mastered selectors, you'll be parsing the jQuery documentation
to write simple and straightforward DOM manipulation code.
There are a lot of quizzes in this course, so
you'll have plenty of practice manipulating the DOM with jQuery as you go.
Are you ready to get started?